I want to show some warning signs of a
disrespectful wife and just some
patterns that I've noticed that you can
see in relationship about who runs them
let's let's pull it up married yeah no
she's the best she's a saint and she
puts up with me and uh run jokes by her
do you really yeah like she I say this
just going to you know nowadays is
always that should I it's so weird now
okay so he he admits a couple things
she's a saint and she puts up typically
men with this mindset actually have a
wife that is not a saint degrades him to
make him think that he is the problem
just just what I've noticed and
typically the men like that talk like
this sort of put their wife on a
pedestal remember she should be talking
High higher of you than you speak of her
because she is supposed to be serving
you